the more the mob wins in thing in
situations like this
the more they're allowed to get away
with this violence like now in portland
we're hearing
they're they're dropping felony charges
even on antifa people who confessed
the more they do this the more people
realize they're untouchable
the more you'll get judges dropping to
their knees and
and just groveling and begging them to
leave them alone this is so wrong
that it would this appeal thing or this
goes to that judge that's so wrong they
should go to a higher court
or to some external authority that can
replace the judge
if it's found that there was impropriety
that he overlooked bro
it's it's you're right you're absolutely
right and i think it's just at this
point i think we need to recognize
what's happening
and uh here's what's happening fox news
most portland riot suspects won't be
prosecuted u.s attorney reveals
charges have been dismissed against 58
of the 97 people arrested during the
unrest last year
here's my favorite part david beauchard
admitted
he put a customs and border protection
officer in a choke hold
charles comfort was indicted by a grand
jury of civil disorder
for twice charging at portland police
officers and
hitting them with a shield and kicking a
third officer while being arrested
both men faced federal charges stemming
from their actions
but bouchard and comfort are among
dozens of portland federal arrestees who
whose cases were dismissed or
are being deferred without so much as a
day behind bars
what does that mean deferred so they
they basically say
you we're not going to do anything right
now we could later on then eventually it
expires or something
so uh they admitted it like literally a
dude admits to
attacking cops this is why i've been
i've been harsh on on the remain the
police that are remaining right now okay
so
so why is this happening though because
the police are arresting them antifa
these rioters and they're bringing them
in
and then the d.a right who is an elected
official right
then says antifa you're free to go it's
not the police so it's like it's it's
like a sorting algorithm
where the cops just are grabbing people
and they're like i'm a neutral
neutral enforcer of the law and then
once they send all the people the d.a
the d.a goes uh are you a democrat
you're free to go are you far left
you're free to go whoa whoa whoa
is that a moga hat lock him up throw the
book at him uh
progressive sorry about that sorry for
wasting your time ah conservative
lock em up yeah did you take a look at
what's going on what happened in new
york with like the proud boys fighting
with antifa
proud boys got four years in prison oh
yeah antifa ran away
now i guess that's the fault of the
proud boys for trusting cops that's
really
i find that really funny that these are
the kind of people that go around saying
like thank you officer thank you
so when after they got into a fight with
andyva and the cops show up the proud
boys were like hello officer
thank you here's my name and information
and the cops smiled and said
now i'm gonna lock you in prison for
four years antifa they're free to go
because they left
and then that and that's that's that's
what i find particularly funny about all
this
that we've now got what a year of
the far left and antifa being cut loose
they keep arresting them they keep
getting let go
conservatives are getting like solitary
confinement for what happened
in dc just like really brutal conditions
you look at chauvin you look at what's
going on with written house and
conservatives are still sitting there
not all of them a lot of them have
actually abandoned cops at this point
but they're still sitting there going
like
i think it's okay that cops are
arresting conservatives and putting them
in prison and
then antifa gets cut loose i'm like no i
think that's pretty bad
if we stay on that track in like a year
what do you think's gonna happen
all of the conservative activists who so
much has stepped foot outside
or dare open their small business
they'll get locked up
antifa can go and burn a building down
and the da's gonna be like i'm so sorry
we wasted your time sir
i'm so sorry okay okay i got i gotta
pull back the hyper a little bit
the guy who burned down the police
department at least he's getting prison
time yeah
but a bunch of these people who actually
set fires like one lady
uh she got charged like multiple no
actually i think if you set a building
on fire they catch you you're going to
get arrested they're going they're
actually going to hold you
but the people who are literally
attacking cops are getting away with it
one lady had like five felonies they
dropped the charges let her go with no
bail
and then she set fire to the police
building the union building in portland
and then they arrested her and then
released her with no bail again
that's why i'm like maybe it's time to
get out of the cities and just you know
be responsible for yourself because you
can't you can't trust a system to do its
job anymore
the the we've we've been seeing these
stories for
months now that far left district
attorneys have been getting elected
and these are people like you know kim
fox who dropped the charge against jesse
smilet
these are the kind of people you're
getting so sure the cops are
are just following the law i'm sorry man
if these people keep electing democrats
who keep passing insane laws and
electing progressive district attorneys
who won't prosecute
progressives ah you can tell me the cops
being neutral but
they're just propping up these corrupt
democrats and these corrupt da's
so so what you're saying i think what
you're introducing is like this
two-sided coin where conservatives need
to both leave the big cities where this
is happening
because let's be real if those
conservatives hadn't been in that crowd
with antiva they never would have been
arrested in the first place
but they have a right to demonstrate
whatever as long as they're not being
violated
what do you mean conservatives in the
crowd so what the people who are
arrested alongside of antifa in portland
what do you mean so like the people who
went in and the d.a just throws the book
at them in these big blue cities
so in new york for instance proud boys
were at an event
right and antifo was outside protesting
and everywhere the
proud boys tried going antifa would be
like staying on the street and hollering
at him
one guy got robbed they stole his
backpack so the proud boys charged at
antifa got into a fight
and then walked away gloating and
laughing about it and live streaming it
antifa ran off
and then when the cops came the proud
boys were like thank you officer we
appreciate it and then the cops slapped
cuffs on him and you know not right at
that moment they got indicted for gang
violence
so i'm not saying literally at antifa
protests right the cops are going into
the wrestling conservatives okay
however there was one instance i think
it was in portland
where a bunch of conservatives were out
protesting and the cops literally
guarded a bunch of antifa i think it's i
think i just find that hilarious
and then we did see you know some people
throw their blue lives matter the thin
blue line flags in the dirt and stomp on
them
but i just like you know in in this town
south of minneapolis this woman
got a couple arrest warrants i think
like nine charges because she opened her
wine and coffee bar
and the cops tracked her down in a
different state like
30 miles away in a different state and
arrested her and brought her back and
she's
going to be charged with all these
crimes meanwhile the far left gets away
with
i mean literally a couple dozen people
died in these riots
it's gonna keep happening i'm thinking
about well maybe we'll talk about this
later there's a video i just saw
of a cop pulling a girl over who was
like driving with their
kid and would start screaming at him he
was a murderer yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then she was calling
him like you'll never be white you wish
you were you can't be
you you're useless and i was just
thinking about the kid like
the hitler youth hitler made sure to get
little kids
involved early to brainwash them when
they were like nine yeah what do you
think they're doing in schools right now
exactly and so i'm afraid of what these
kids
not just next next year what's going to
happen but like in seven years when
these six-year-olds and nine-year-olds
are like
becoming politically active how
dangerous that
brainwashing is he has his mom's saying
that horrible stuff
and she's a teacher yes maybe to a cop
right in front of him it didn't get even
represented well the the the funny thing
is
i guess what happened was the cop drove
past her so she pulled out she was
driving and she pulls out her phone
so he pulls her over and then she's like
i pulled out my phone to record you
it's like he's just driving down the
street are you nuts
yeah these people have gone insane and i
blame you
to a great degree social media it's
empowering these lunatics and then you
have the grifters on the left who don't
care they just want to make money so
they'll just say whatever
then you're the true believers who are
just loving it
they're they're loving the media they're
loving the social media they're loving
the manipulation
and then you get seemingly regular
people losing their minds
and screaming that this cop is a
murderer who wants to be white if i'd
seen my mom do that when i was eight
to a cop i would have lost so much
respect for cops and felt so empowered
to just
just trash that that establishment oh
treat like they're nothing they're never
gonna harm me i can do whatever i want
in this world
as long as i call them racist or or
denigrate them for the way they look
i'm not gonna blame every single cop in
every single jurisdiction for what we're
seeing in these big cities
but these big city cops are bad because
the good ones have left
for okay so we have a situation in
baltimore we have a very far left
progressive state's attorney marilyn
mosby
and it's unfortunate because i've talked
to police officers they say you know we
arrest people
we take with central booking but it
doesn't matter because they're just
going to let them go free
and so now we have a situation where
cops really aren't
out doing their job because they're sick
of it because they're like why would i
be there
number one i could get in a conflict and
be called a racist if something happens
between a white cop and a black person
and then two they're just gonna let them
go free you know we have 11 time repeat
offenders on our streets
doing violent crimes and it's insane
and so you know our state's attorney
she's already said she's not going to
prosecute any low-level crimes so you
can be a drug dealer you can be a
prostitute you can be all of these
things
but you better wear a mask so and you
can't have a gun you can't have a gun
yes oh well the law-abiding citizens
right right
we had someone that was arrested an 11
time repeat offender
and he ended up killing someone and so
now he's finally i guess locked up we'll
see
but i mean it's crazy you know 11th time
11th time is the charm
11th time the charm they say yes
11 yes yeah i'm not surprised at all by
cops in baltimore just being like why
would i do this and i wouldn't be
surprised if then they start quitting
and then you have a shortage which is oh
we do we're down 700 police officers
and i think they said 500 more should be
on patrol considering the population but
we just don't have it
you know why that is because the good
cops left yeah because the cops who are
like i'm not going to support the
crooked
politicians i'm not going to waste my
time i'm going to leave
and i respect them for doing it the the
the political system is broken in these
places and unfortunately
you know uh if you if if you live in
these places
and you want to know who the guilty
party is you need only look in the
mirror
to uh throw shout out to v for vendetta
the regular people who keep voting in
these democrats
i mean look they had an opportunity to
elect you
they voted for the other guy they did so
i i growing up in chicago it's been
under democrat
super majority for like 80 years and it
never gets better
it only gets worse and yet you have
people complaining about all day every
day and i still hear from these people
just make sure when you go vote you vote
democrat and i'm like why
look i don't care what party they are
vote for the person is going to do a
good job
but how about we stop this single party
rule in these big cities
because now what's going to happen is
the cops aren't going to do their job
700 officer shortage in baltimore it's
going to get less safe it's going to get
more chaotic and then are people
actually going to wake up to the to the
to the fact that they're voting in bad
people no they probably will just leave
it's a cyclical problem too you
mentioned earlier like if a d.a
lets people go it's like are you going
to vote for trump okay you're free to go
are you get in there like literally
whether they mean to or not or maybe
they do mean to that's political
well a political party is is deciding
the fate of these criminals
you realize in portland when this guy
admits to attacking a federal
officer and i believe it's a felony
there's
how much you want to bet at least one of
these people has thought
if we actually charge this guy and
convict him he can't vote democrat
anymore
felons you know it's a dark but it's not
even that we should we should cut these
felons loose and not charge them so they
can retain their right to vote because
they
we know they're going to vote for our
guy and they're making trump look bad
uh but you get a conservative in new
york and they're gonna be like give
those people felonies
so that they can never vote again and
there you go
and then still they're uh i find it
really fascinating i do
um when i have conversations about big
tech with with some conservatives
and they're like we shouldn't regulate
these big tech companies and i'm like
okay well you know in 10 years when your
ideology no longer exists don't come
crawling to me and you know asking for
help to spread the word i'm not going to
do it
if there's no free speech and these big
tech companies are not regulated
the same thing is happening now with
cops there are there are a lot of
conservatives surprisingly
that are tweeting the cities voted for
this let them have no cups
but i still see a lot of conservatives
who are like no no no we have to support
the officers in new york and i'm like
dude the office of new york
the officers in new york are literally
committing crimes
like we went over this the other day
when when bill de blasio illegally
appropriates money
to to paint black lives matter with
taxpayer funds in front of trump's
building and then 27 officers stand
guard
and and arrest anyone who opposes the
illegal actions of the mayor like
they're aiding and abetting a very
serious crime and corruption do they
know he
broke the law to get that thing painted
i think the rest of the law is no excuse
for breaking it especially for a cop
i mean yeah you you listen if if
someone's
if if someone says hey come with me and
you walk into a bank and they hand you a
bag and say hold this bag and then pull
out a gun
and then you're standing there like i
wonder what's happening you're going to
get in trouble you're helping the
criminal
so in these cities you you have these
cops who are literally aiding and
abetting
criminal activities from very very
corrupt politicians
and and and they're saying it's not my
fault
i i didn't do it if you know someone
else should do something about it
it's not me this you well you voted for
it and i'm like okay you all voted for
it
okay if everybody in the city they get
exactly what they deserve
the conservatives who remain after
losing these elections before the
election i wasn't saying this
after the election i say maybe you got
to leave these places because otherwise
what's going to happen is
over a long enough period of time
progressive district attorneys
okay it's it's you've ever go to casino
you guys have been to a casino yeah
okay you know casinos win the games just
have
a slight margin in their favor so when
you win
ten thousand dollars off a ten dollar
bet somehow or whatever you're playing
and you're all cheering the casino's
happy they like that you know why
because everyone around you hears the
celebration and they start gambling more
and all that matters is that if the
house wins 50.1 percent of the time
they're profitable over a long enough
period of time they will win and keep
getting money
if these big cities are run by corrupt
far leftists
and and just de blasio people like him
who are stealing money
and you have cops supporting them over a
long enough period of time
the left and the right could be arrested
in equal numbers the right will go to
prison the left will be released
in 10 years what is that what does that
mean a bunch of conservative felons who
can't vote
and a bunch of insane violent offenders
who are voting to their hearts content
so i think what we need to do with the
pro with the issue that we have with
policing
is we need to separate for conservatives
we need to separate out the idea
the concept of policing from the actual
police who are enforcing these bad laws
because they are bad laws this is in
fact what is voted for there are cops
who are doing bad things out there
and arresting like small business owners
and parents are just trying to work
the idea of policing i think is very
important conservatives are inclined
towards structure
they want organization accountability
and responsibility
which is what we're losing so we need to
separate out
these terrible cops that we have right
now in these big cities who are
enforcing bad laws
from the actual idea the underlying idea
of police as a whole policing how do you
how do you how do you even do that isn't
it i don't know yeah so so even this
this woman who got arrested
for opening her cafe yeah she was
arrested by a local sheriff's department
you know 40 miles outside or i think
we're like 50 miles outside of
minneapolis
so this was a small town sheriff's
department tracked her down and said
how dare you try and serve coffee during
a pandemic and
arrested her that's crazy to me because
the small town sheriffs are supposed to
be like
in your community and understand where
you're coming from and like that you
want to have your own business
and you're supposed to have that
camaraderie and it looks like we're
losing that too
seems sad thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you